boycottez non parce que je pense qu'on a
besoin en ce moment dans la période
tellement réjouissante et joyeuse qu'on
traverse d'avoir une émission de
divertissement de la sûreté etc et de la
musique c'est plutôt pas mal en revanche
il faut savoir où on met les pieds c'est
à dire qu'il faut savoir effectivement
que c'est une remise de prix qui est
orienté comme toutes les remises de prix
finalement qui ne sont pas régis par le
vote du public et c'est comme ça ça
laisse un potentiel d'ailleurs c'est les
professionnels de la musique c'est des
mecs travaillent dans des maisons dix
sont des producteurs qui choisissent qui
sélectionne les artistes qui ensuite
vote pour les artistes donc en fait il
ya de la cooptation y à du copinage
c'est normal ya des intérêts y avait
conflit d'intérêts c'est comme pour les
prix littéraires par exemple c'est
exactement la même chose les maisons
d'édition qui choisissent donc là c'est
la même donc effectivement chaque année
on s'étonne d'avoir certains artistes
qui sont là d'autres qui sont absents je
me souviens en 2016 c'était l'année
kenji girac moi j'étais déjà à la radio
on entend desquelles j partout il était
absent des victoires de la musique là
pour grand corps malade c'est vrai que
c'est un
gros test pour ça il faudrait soit
changer le nom parce que c'est pas
vraiment les espoirs de la musique avec
un grand m j'ai rangé le système but est
d'amener que parce que entre grand corps
malade c'est censé être les artistes qui
font l'actualité musicale et hubert
félix thiéfaine - hubert félix thiéfaine
je l'écouté quand j'avais 16 ans c'était
un champ à certains chanteurs j'ai rien
contre lui mais c'est quand même un
chanteur pour les fumeurs de pet bon
très bien il est là tant mieux pour lui
mais à un moment donné il ya quand même
quelques petites des incohérences
effectivement jean mi oui il faut les
boycotter de quoi manger a écrit les
mots côté faut les supprimer surtout moi
ce genre de cérémonie ne sais absolument
rien de la même façon que les molières
sadibou et césar samedi absolument rien
mais c'est des gens déjà qu'ils sont
adulés toute l'année qui sont bien pays
qui foutent pas grand-chose tendu pour
eux c'est ça c'est ça quels sont les
besoins en plus de passer une soirée les
aduler sont déjà du lait toute l'année
et puis moi je suis désolé c'est
peut-être un peu populiste mais je pense
que c'est aussi dur de construire un
beau mur de construire une piscine ou
piscine ou de construire une montre que
d'écrire une chanson il n'ya pas les
victoires des horlogers pas des
carreleurs etc voilà donc à quoi ça sert
une soirée rien si c'était faire plaisir
à la prochaine qui produisent et qui kok
thlok la tête j'aurais musculation
absolument sofia je vois que toi que tu
dis non toi aussi tu es pour le maintien
de ces ces victoires de la musique ah
non le contraire
finalement oui ou non je pense tout
simplement que cette cérémonie elle a
plus de valeur dans le sens où elle
n'est pas représentative si tous les
rappeurs par exemple comme jul etc c'est
eux qui vendent le plus de cd et au
final c'est pas eux qu'on retrouve dans
la cérémonie joue enfin je trouve que
c'est pas assez représentées bien sûr et
pourtant les audiences sont plutôt
bonnes on a d'ailleurs le graphique qui
va vous détailler les audiences sur ces
dernières années les audiences se
tiennent se maintiennent c'est peut-être
pourquoi tu dis non malek les odeurs se
maintiennent mais moi c'est une belle
soirée c'est un bon divertissement
l'année dernière j'avais qui fait la
prestation diana camorra il y avait eu
lieu qu'à mes jambes j'ai passé une très
belle soirée après on peut reparler du
boycott tous les ans ça va rien changer
ça restera la soirée du mépris de
l'autre soit de la condescendance jeu
sur le populaire en fait c'est l'anti
c'est la soirée antipopulaires moi y'a
un truc plutôt qui me dérange on avait
alors le casting de fin de classement
des plus gros vendeurs et la belle série
en a dit que sr j'allais recevoir un
prix c'est vrai il va recevoir le prix
de l'album le plus stream est sûr que
moi y'a un truc qui me dérange c'est
qu'on n'a ni la musique urbaine dans ces
catégories les plus grands prix du
médicament mis de côté tout à fait en
valorisant fait l'impact donc le fait
qu'ils soient streamé mais pas du tout
sur la qualité artistique voilà donc en
dénigrant encore une fois la musique
urbaine moi c'est ça qui me dérange
d'ailleurs c'est que juste pablo tu es
plutôt d'accord ouais moi je suis
d'accord avec lui parce que justement
jul tout ça c'est très bien que c'est
des gros gros gros vendeurs de disques
si c'est un minou vendeurs de disques
bawin 6,6 et les plus gros vendeurs de
disques c'est que les gens les
apprécient mais que ce soit jul soprano
dams au tout le monde le problème c'est
que là ils sont pas représentés moi
quand je bois l'émission j'ai pas la
cour d'être présenté mon style c'est
plutôt le style de rap urbaine je me
sens pas du tout représentée là dedans
et il n'y a pas là qui pensent
les cous des écoutes paul c'est bien
pour eux parce que ça leur fait une
petite promotion c'est bien pas besoin
c'est différent encore c'est encore un
autre style la presse et les goûts et
les couleurs ou moi je pense qu'il faut
boycotter parfait déjà passé les maisons
de disques qui font la loi je trouve pas
ça normal en plus de sens et que dans le
groupe des six en votant il ya l'un des
groupes où la majorité des gens qui
votent ces maisons de disques pour moi
c'est comme si on autorise en fait le
président a voté à l'assemblée nationale
enfin sears a complètement déplacé du
coup cet excès corrompu et encore une
fois on voit que ce monde est régi par
l'argent que partout où on va c'est
l'argent qui régit tout pour moi ça me
débecte parce que normand c'est juste un
truc on devrait regarder pour se
divertir et c'est finalement se rend
compte qu'il ya quand même des enjeux
financiers en plus de ça je voudrais
ajouter que je trouve que cette
cérémonie elle est particulièrement
ennuyeuse parce que la plupart du temps
on voit des artistes remercier leur a
ouvert sa saison là moi je serai pas
intérêt à regarder c'est que ces genres
d'accord enfin c'est trop ennuyant ou
d'émissions de télé de divertissement
pur dites nous ce que vous en pensez
bien sûr sur twitter je pourrais pas
passer une soirée à garder les victoires
de la musique c'est non pas oui mais les
performances et sympathique charlotte
c'est qu'on peut en retirer mais que tu
regardes sépare sociaux etc voilà des
gens qui font des monos la coi pour
remercier
la confiance est la bienvenue une équipe
est toujours dit assistons tous
ces
personnes par rapport à tous alors du
coup qu'est ce qu'il faudrait changer
pour rendre ces victoires de la musique
accessible plus inclusive sauf que
derrière je sais que cyril hanouna il va
mettre en place une cérémonie en caux la
bavette skyrock pour insérer la musique
urbaine et je pense que ça c'est
vraiment une bonne idée ça va enfin
pouvoir donner ma place aux grands
rappeurs c'est un projet qui revient
souvent mais d'humaniser ce journaliste
rap en parle très souvent il faudrait en
fait ne pas dépendre des victoires de la
musique et faire aujourd'hui le rap
c'est la musique la plus écoutée cnsm
réalité c'est un constat il faudrait
faire une cérémonie y avait eu à
l'époque c'était il ya très très
longtemps bah vous faire une cérémonie
du rap français est comme ça on n'aura
pas à se plaindre et on fera la fête
entre nous et qu'il fera non non ça vous
découvrez les lobbys en fait
monsieur interpréter ce tout fonctionne
comme ça l'académie des césars
fonctionne comme ça les prix littéraires
fonctionne comme ça les victoires de la
musique fonctionne comme ça les nrj
music awards aussi oui les plaintes et
les polémiques autour d'eux les
victoires de la musique n'ont rien à
voir avec les plaintes et les polémiques
autour des césars et autour d'eux des
prix littéraires s'il a toujours des
artistes eux mêmes c'est rare qu'on ait
des acteurs qui disent je ne suis pas
représenté aux césar c'est une honte on
a eu dany boon un moment pas parce que
là le genre de la comédie était un peu
exclu des césars mais sur les victoires
de la musique j'ai vraiment l'impression
que tous les ans on a des maths pokora
comme des arracheurs très établies qui
montent au créneau pour dire franchement
c'est ça monte ça nourrit je suis dacc
je suis d'accord avec vous mais mais
mais qu'à moitié parce que les césars ça
commence quand même aussi à grogner sur
le l'implication même en fait de
l'académie des césars dans les votes en
fait la solution et c'est ce que vous
demandiez de salaire agathe la solution
c'est d'impliquer le public tout
simplement et on le fait pour une seule
catégorie c'est la chanson originale de
l'année on devrait faire pour toutes les
catégories comme a dit pablo voilà c'est
au public de décider et de voter et à ce
moment là c'est vrai que c'est plus un
peu de temps et c'est plus sympa un
public qui décide de tout c'est les
ventes c'est le public hk oui est ce que
son nom puisque tu vois bien que les
meilleures ventes ne sont pas
représentés bail alors le supprimer tu
dis est
entière bon d'accord moi
[Applaudissements]